what is the status of everyone's
friendships i mean have you forgiven the
ladies angelina
it took me a long time mentally to
within myself to say all right look
enough is enough i would like to sit
down with these ladies
well let's dive right down into things
that you guys are actually going into
your own sort of shore bubble for this
season
bringing the family with you as well i
tested negative for the kovich
positive for the romans
[Applause]
they can't show any of this on tv
what was that experience like for you
guys mike why don't you kick things off
uh it was definitely a first for us to
uh obviously film during covid
uh but it wasn't a first for us to
quarantine we've been quarantining for
many years jersey shore in various
locations
and um i have faith uh or a lot of faith
in our dynamic we've known each other
for over 10 years we've
you know i think we filmed almost 150
episodes
together so we're very excited to bring
this season to you guys
it's always funny it's always humorous
we're very excited for everyone to see
it
all good video what was the biggest
challenge
about being in this bubble with each
other i mean yes
like mike said you guys are used to kind
of quarantining together but this is
extreme situation here with covet
yeah i mean look it's a lot different
we're not interacting with the outside
world
but we haven't really we stopped doing
that kind of a long time ago you know a
lot of the drama was
within ourselves and within this family
and we went into this resort with a lot
of unfinished business obviously that
everybody knows about
and to be locked up with each other
like and you can't i don't want to say
you can't escape like we're prisoners
but like
you know it was uh it was exactly what
we needed
and what this family needed and it's
just
the most drama we've ever we've had in a
long time because of it
well vinnie bold statement there but yes
honey we have heard that there has been
a lot of drama
and we've seen it kind of unfold over
the past what year or so and now you
guys are going to be hitting it head on
a lot of it stems from angelina's
wedding so
you know now we're you're confronting
that you all seem to
you know you usually make things out
stronger than you were
before you know any time that there's a
rift angelina will we see things be
repaired
this season especially when it comes to
your wedding it was a long
year to say the least but i have to
commend the boys because the boys
definitely stepped up and
did so much i swear so much just to get
us
in the same place the same hotel yeah
look at mike over there he knows
uh i mean it needs so like stepped up so
much
to get this family back together or try
at least uh
and you know you guys are gonna just
have to tune in to see what happens but
it i had to we all had to basically sit
down and
figure it out head on like you said like
you said before angelina
you're the lice to my hair
you're the fly to our i love that
what is the status of everyone's
friendships i mean have you forgiven the
ladies angelina
it took me a long time mentally to
within myself
to say all right look enough is enough i
would like to sit down with these ladies
and thank god for the boys that they
were able to get
you know i don't know about everybody i
can't say everybody right now because i
don't want to give too much away but
they were able to get us in the same
place at the same time
i don't want to give too much away after
that but you guys are going to have to
stay tuned and see what happens
fair enough well jesus with this who's
the biggest pot stir
of the bunch what's funny is that like
sometimes it's like who you least expect
um
yeah i mean me and paulie like instigate
a lot but we don't really do it
maliciously
um we kind of just drop little bombs
like little little sparks here and there
and then like we just walk away when
it's on fire
and he likes to do it to me especially
oh yeah i'm a master at that
uh oh vinnie over there stir in that pot
now who spells her partner were you guys
most concerned about
joining in and really fitting in with
the butt bunch in this bubble in vegas
um that's a good one i mean uh i think
lauren fits in great obviously we've
known her
for a while chris was kind of new and
he's kind of quiet right
so i don't really know you know we i
always worry about like the quieter ones
you gotta watch out for those quiet ones
mike what do you think
did you i was excited that all the
families
uh were involved in this season because
it's called jersey shore family vacation
you know we're not necessarily in our
20s
at the club every single night but we're
still really fun and i love the
trajectory of where the show is
now um so you know you're going to see a
lot more of my wife you're going to see
dina's
husband angelina's uh husband um
obviously uncle nino comes in so uh even
angelina's
grandmother my grandma he is
feisty girlfriend oh listen grandma
do not play with that woman that woman
is on fire
she's on fire now mike you mentioned
that you're
more involved in literally yeah i love
that your wife is more involved well all
of your
your spouses and significant others are
more involved in the show this season
but mike you
in particular i feel like we see a lot
unfold between
you and your wife and things get really
intimate and you really
uh navigate some private moments in
there why did you feel like you wanted
to have the cameras around for some of
these more private moments
my life has been um you know open book
the past
you know over 10 years and um honesty is
always the best policy and it has always
helped me
uh and my wife or you know navigate
through everything so
um and i think that's what draws a lot
of viewers
and and fans to the show because it's a
it's a it's a real reality show
i applaud anyone that's on reality tv
that's authentic and genuine and i pride
myself to be that way
yeah is there anything off limits i
don't think so i i live
my life is full of integrity peace and
purpose so
you know what i mean i walk it like i
talk it so i i think that's the
allure or you know or why people are
attracted to me
why people are attracted to you
absolutely mike
absolutely such now vinnie is there
anything for you that's off limits
you don't want to see a lot of the stuff
that goes on in my life that's where
that's for a different network
oh use my god come on
yeah that's like mtv after dark but um
besides that
uh everything is pretty much you know
it's just this is a part of
our life and um you know we always
we say like we create our story a lot of
the time
so you know if anyone ever looks bad on
tv or whatever it's like okay like
maybe that's kind of what you put out
there and then if you want to change
that you have the power to change that
too the camera is just following you
um and then you know obviously sometimes
life will be thrown at you and we're
there to support each other
and um if you want to put it on tv you
can but
um for me it's been pretty much open
book but like i said besides those other
things you you might not want to see
i mean angelina tmi
all righty you were there for most of
them come on
um you wish i was there for most of them
it's crazy now um
mike i got to ask you this too here
buddy you guys were in vegas did you
feel like your sobriety was tested at
all while you were in that bubble
oh no i have such a strong foundation
now i'm actually
uh you'll see me post on december 1st
i'm going to be uh
five years clean and sober and hopefully
throwing a party if possible
given any code 19 restrictions but i'm
very excited to to come across five
years clean and sober i have a very
strong
foundation of recovery um and
um yeah i'm just very proud of that that
aspect of my life yeah